for as long as humans have looked at the
stars we have wondered how they got
there and what lies beyond them
scientists have long searched for a
simple theory that explains how the
universe works
a theory of everything
many theories have been tested and so
far every one of them has failed to
fully explain what we see in our
universe but there is one particularly
enticing idea that some theoretical
physicists think might just be it string
theory
string theory is finite it doesn't blow
up
it doesn't collapse on itself that's why
we believe in it other theories do
collapse other theories do blow up but
string theory does not
[Music]
dr michio kaku has spent decades
grappling with and attempting to answer
some of life's biggest questions
what happened before the big bang
are there other universes
what lies on the other side of creation
the other side of a black hole
are gateways possible wormholes higher
dimensions do we live in a multiverse
all these questions cannot be answered
using our present-day understanding
when dr kaku talks about our present day
understanding he means our current best
theories about the way the universe
works
in truth they contradict each other and
sometimes even give conflicting results
albert einstein's general theory of
relativity works perfectly well for
predictions about the movements of stars
and galaxies
but doesn't work when applied to the
behavior of subatomic particles
conversely quantum theory is great with
atoms but predicts the whole universe
should collapse into a black hole which
it clearly doesn't because we're all
still here
so will we ever find a single theory
that explains everything
two thousand years ago pythagoras asked
himself that question
the great greek mathematician said that
there must be a unifying principle a
paradigm by which to summarize the vast
creation
that we see all around us of the
universe that we know and he looked
around and saw a liar string
you pluck a liar string and you get a
note you pluck another one you get
another note and then he said aha
the mathematics of music is rich enough
to explain the diversity of everything
we see around us
and then only recently have we come up
with a new idea based on the pythagorean
idea of music
in other words string theory so how do
we go from pythagoras musical musings to
proper physics
the first port of call would be a
particle accelerator like the large
hadron collider at cern in switzerland
where tiny particles are smashed to
pieces in high energy collisions and
then closely studied these experiments
are our best way of testing theories
about how the universe works so what
does string theory predict we would see
we now believe that all these subatomic
particles hundreds of subatomic
particles that we get by smashing
protons at the large asian collider
they're nothing but
musical notes as pythagoras believed
if i had a super microscope and i could
peer into an electron what would i see i
would see
a rubber band
a vibrating rubber band of course dr
kaku doesn't mean an actual rubber band
but rather something rubber band like
or to put it another way the strings and
string theory and just like the strings
on a musical instrument if you put some
energy into them they vibrate it
vibrates one way we call it an electron
we vibrate it another way it's called
the neutrino
we vibrate another way it's called the
quark but it's the same rubber band
so string theory offers a tantalizing
possibility an explanation for the vast
variety we see in the universe from the
collisions of stars to the collisions of
atoms
of course string theory is just that a
theory
its critics point out that many of its
predictions are untestable something dr
kaku himself acknowledges
its proponents though consider it to be
the best hope of unifying physics dr
kaku believes string theory could even
explain the mystery that is dark matter
dark matter makes up most of the matter
of the universe
it is invisible
and it holds the galaxies together but
how do we prove it
we think that dark matter could be the
next octave of the string if you could
magnify all the particles you see around
us
we see a lot of rubber bands
a lot of rubber bands vibrating at
different frequencies but the rubber
band has higher octaves
that we think is dark matter if dr kaku
is right the huge complexity of the
entire universe could be reduced to the
simple and elegant vibration of strength
i think that one thing that people
should realize is that
physics at the fundamental level gets
simpler and simpler the deeper we go
but becomes more powerful the deeper we
go the universe is simpler than we
thought
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video